- We have not done anything
to the non-governmental
organizations
that are getting
federal grant money.
And they're becoming
the travel agencies
for these illegal immigrants.
They're the ones
putting them on buses,
putting them on planes,
giving them 13 to $1,400 each
of taxpayer money.
And so we should be able
to revoke those licenses
of these 501(c)(3)
organizations, like
a Catholic Charities,
that is operating, and
aiding and abetting
human and sex trafficking
here in the state of Texas.
So there are many things
that the governor could do.
(gentle music)
- I'm Dave Rubin
and joining me today
is a retired Army
Lieutenant Colonel,
chairman of the
Republican Party of Texas,
and candidate for governor
of Texas, Allen West.
Welcome back to,
"The Rubin Report."
- Good to be with you,
Dave, and merry Christmas.
I have to make one correction,
I stepped down from being
the chairman back in June,
right before I announced
the run for governor,
'cause I didn't want any
conflict of interest.
But everything's going
very well here in Texas.
- Well, merry Christmas to you.
And I like being
corrected by the guest
on the very first
sentence of an interview.
I feel, we're not gonna edit,
I always tell my guests,
"We don't edit for content,"
so I like it, you're
setting the tone.
I appreciate the
fact check on that.
How are you my friend?
You know, I realized like a
minute before we started here
that we've actually never
done the one-on-one.
You've been on the show once,
you were on with Chad Robichaux,
we were talking
about all the work
that you guys do with veterans.
But we've actually never
done the one-on-one.
That was a couple of years ago.
You've had an
interesting couple years.
- Yeah, it's been-
- Haven't ya?
- Yeah, it has been an
interesting couple years.
I, by the grace of God, I
probably should not be here,
'cause last year,
Memorial Day weekend,
I had an accident
on my motorcycle,
75 miles an hour on
a interstate highway.
And you know, the fact
that I'm still alive
is very, very great.
And so it's a pleasure to be
here with you and everything.
And I'm down here in Livingston,
Texas, at VFW Post 8568.
And I love coming, you know,
getting out of the big cities,
and getting down to
the small rural areas,
and especially
being with veterans.
What a great thing
to do, as you know,
as we go into the
holiday season also.
- Yeah, and you guys do some
tremendous work with veterans.
Before we get into
everything you're doing now,
and why you're running
for governor of Texas,
and everything else,
can we just do the
quick two-minute bio
on you and your story, your
service, that sort of thing,
just so those that
don't know you,
will fully know you, and
then we'll go from there.
- Well, I gotta tell you,
when you think about
the American dream,
and everything
that America offers
to each and every one of us,
I call it the equality
of opportunity,
and not equality of outcomes.
You know, 60 years ago,
I was born in a
blacks-only hospital,
in the inner city
of Atlanta, Georgia.
I grew up in the
same neighborhood
that gave us Dr. Martin Luther
King Jr. there in Atlanta.
My dad was a World
War II corporal
in the United States Army,
and he served this
country at a time
when he was not seen equal to
everyone in a segregated Army.
My mother did 25 years
plus civilian service
with the Marine
headquarters in Atlanta.
My older brother was an
infantryman in Marine Corps,
and was wounded in Vietnam.
At the age of 15,
my dad challenged me
to be the first
officer in our family.
And on 31, July, 1982,
I was commissioned as
a Second Lieutenant
at the University of Tennessee.
I served 22 years
active duty service
for the United States Army,
as a field artilleryman,
also as a paratrooper.
13 different countries,
three different combat zones.
The story for our family
doesn't end there.
My nephew, who is my
older brother's son,
he is now a Lieutenant Colonel
in the United States Army,
continuing to serve.
I've been married for 32
years, I have a great wife.
She's really the brain
trust of this couple.
She has an MBA and a PhD,
and I met her when she
was a business professor
at Kansas State University.
We have two daughters,
Aubrey and Austen, 28 and 24.
And six months ago,
we became grandparents
to an incredible
little grandson,
by the name of Jaxton Bernard.
So that's pretty
much some of my life,
and, you know, I had a
great opportunity to serve
in the state of Florida as
a United States Congressman.
And back in 2004, I
got the opportunity
to come back to Texas.
My last duty sound
was Fort Hood, Texas.
And so here I am, now
running to be the governor
of the state of Texas.
- Well, you definitely handled
the resume question well.
So let's talk a little
bit about the states,
'cause you mentioned
the sort of big two,
or the shining stars, at
least from where I'm at
at the moment, as you know,
I'm in crazy Los Angeles,
California as we tape this.
But you mentioned Florida,
where you were a Congressman.
You're running for
governor in Texas.
Are you sort of
pleased to see the way
the states have gone
in different directions
at this point,
that the federalist
system is sort of working
when you see hubs of freedom,
like Florida and Texas,
and I'll throw
Tennessee in there,
and a couple other states,
while you watch some of the
blue states kinda crumble?
- Well, the interesting thing is
I think we need to reassert
that sense of federalism,
and what we see as far
as that understanding
of the 10th Amendment,
where it says
that those powers not delegated
to the federal government
are reserved to the
states and to the people.
And that's where we have a
huge constitutional crisis
here in the state of Texas,
because Article IV, Section
4 of the Constitution,
there are two things that
the federal government
is supposed to guarantee to
every state in the union.
Number one, a republican
form of government,
not Republican Party, but
republican form of government.
And number two, they're
supposed to protect
every state from invasion.
Well, when you have
an administration,
like we see with the
Biden administration,
that has abdicated their
constitutional duty
and responsibility to protect
the sovereignty of Texas,
and the sovereignty of the
United States of America,
Texas has a 1,254 mile border
with a foreign country.
And it is not just an
everyday foreign country,
it's a destabilized
foreign country.
And we see this transnational,
narco-criminal terrorist
organization, known
as the cartels,
really running things
along our border.
And so the founding fathers
and their brilliance
gave the state the ability
to be able to protect itself,
if the federal government
abdicated that.
And so I think that
that's one of the things
we see here in Texas, and
many of the other red states,
is to once again reassert
that ideal of federalism,
the federal government is
supreme over the states
by the Supremacy Clause,
but it has to be that
they're doing things
pursuant thereof to
the Constitution.
And I will challenge anyone,
when we see this
Biden administration,
they're not doing
too many things
pursuant to the Constitution.
- Is the border issue,
you think that's the number
one issue on Texans minds?
I mean, it's a
little hard to gauge,
because on one hand you can
sorta only see the videos
on Fox, or online.
Mainstream won't cover it.
And then it makes it
a little hard to see,
well, what is the
average person seeing?
Do they even know what
they're voting on,
'cause they're not seeing it,
depending on what
news they watch?
- Well, I will tell you
that you talk to people
down here in Texas, and
especially you talk to people
on the border counties,
they will tell you
that's the number one thing.
And I think that it really
came to a forefront,
nationally as an issue,
when we saw those airplanes
that landed in the
middle of the night
in Westchester County, New York,
that had illegal
immigrant minor children,
and those planes
took off from Texas.
And we also know that
there were planes
that had been
landing in Florida,
where I think you may
be looking to come,
and we want you to
come here to Texas,
don't want you to go to Florida.
- Uh oh, who told you to
make the hard sell, man?
Uh oh, uh oh.
- I'm trying, man.
I'm gonna make you an
offer you can't refuse.
But you know, we seen those
planes land in Florida.
We seen those planes
land in Tennessee.
And how interesting,
those planes are
landing in red states.
Those planes are landing
in suburban areas.
But most definitely,
we need to realize
that the United States
of America right now
has an all time high
in drug overdoses,
over 100,000 of our young
people, drug overdoses.
And where is that coming
from? The fentanyl.
And how has fentanyl
getting into
the United States of America?
From China, down in Mexico,
across the border here.
So we've got a drug
trafficking crisis.
We have a human and
sex trafficking crisis.
Texas is the number
one state in America
for human and sex trafficking,
Dallas and Houston.
Maybe you don't wanna
move into Dallas,
but we can talk about suburb.
But Dallas and Houston
are the top two cities
in the country for
sex trafficking.
And we know about the
public health crisis.
Think about this, Dave,
I mean we've got a
federal government
that's telling us, law
abiding American citizens,
what we have to get
injected into our bodies.
But people are coming
across 200,000 a month,
and no one is telling them
they have to have anything
injected in their body.
So we have a public
health crisis as well.
- Were you beyond shocked,
when about a week ago,
maybe 10 days ago,
when Anthony Fauci
was asked about just that?
And you know, they're
talking about a mandate
on planes for domestic
travel, on trains,
and then the reporter
wisely asked him,
"Well, what about the
people at the border?"
And he basically was like, "Ah,
that's a separate
issue altogether."
Not for you guys.
- Yeah, that's fair.
No, it's not for us,
it's very dismissive.
And if you want
to look at spikes,
where we've seen COVID
here in the state of Texas,
you just follow the places
where we have a lot
of concentrations
of illegal immigrants going to,
to include in West Texas.
They've been busing illegal
immigrants out in West Texas,
putting them up in hotels,
and in the man camps,
with some of the oil
and gas field workers.
And you seen a spike out
there in Midland and Odessa.
You see it in the major
cities, like in Houston.
There's an estimation that
the population of Houston
has increased somewhere
between 300,000 to 400,000,
because there was
a pipeline of folks
coming across the
border illegally,
somehow getting transported.
And then they are
bunkered down in Houston,
or some of these other
places, in these stash houses.
So we have a huge issue
that we have to deal with.
- So the easy version of
this, for guys like us,
would be, okay, the
Biden administration
wants to destroy America.
You know, the Democrats
wanna flood the country.
It's all about demographics,
or voting patterns,
or keep the people on
the dole, et cetera.
I mean, do you think it's
as simple as all of that?
Or is there something,
is this ineptitude?
Is this that these people
just don't know how to govern,
don't know what they're doing?
Or do you think it's
something directly nefarious?
- It is nefarious, it's
intentional and purposeful,
because when I look at
this open borders agenda
that was implemented,
unconstitutionally,
I mean, you cannot
give up the sovereignty
of the United States of
America by executive order.
But then you look at H.R.1,
and what H.R.1 talks about,
because both of them came
about at the same time.
And H.R.1 says
that there will be
no voter registration
role review.
There'll be no picture ID,
that we will be doing voting
by unsolicited mail-in ballots,
and online voter registration,
same day voter registration,
same day voting.
And it does talk about
illegals being able to vote.
And you look at
this infrastructure,
the human infrastructure bill,
where they're talking
about granting amnesty.
And so by the end of this year,
we may be looking at close to
2 million illegal immigrants.
This is a record high for
the United States of America,
have crossed the border
and come into this country.
- So I'm sure some
people are watching,
going, "Well, wait a minute,
Abbott's a Republican,
he's over there."
Has he dropped the ball on this?
- Without a doubt, you have
to wonder why the governor
hasn't done a lot better, and
we coulda seen this coming.
That's what leadership
is all about.
Leadership is about
having vision,
and being very prescient.
And so you shoulda taken
all the measures necessary
to ensure that you had our
own Texas military department,
our National Guard, ready
to secure our border,
and make sure that we
did not see this flood
of illegals coming here.
We needed to make sure
that we could stand
on our constitutional right,
Article 1, Section 10, Clause 3,
to be able to secure our border.
And I think another thing,
an executive order from the
governor of state of Texas,
to declare these cartels as
a terrorist organization,
because I was in Iraq,
I was in Afghanistan.
And in Afghanistan,
the Taliban uses opium
as a means to fuel
their efforts.
And so what are they doing here?
They're using fentanyl,
methamphetamines, marijuana.
So it's the exact same thing.
We're fighting an insurgency,
and they're shooting
across the border,
into the state of Texas,
which is an act of war.
If you declare them as a
terrorist organization,
then you go after their
resources and their financing.
You go after their assets, you
freeze it and you seize it.
We have not done anything
to the non-governmental
organizations
that are getting
federal grant money.
And they're becoming
the travel agencies
for these illegal immigrants.
They're the ones
putting them on buses,
putting them on planes,
giving them 13 to $1,400 each
of taxpayer money.
And so we should be able
to revoke those licenses
of these 501(c)(3)
organizations,
like a Catholic Charities,
that is operating and
aiding and abetting
human and sex trafficking
here in the state of Texas.
So there are many things
that a governor could do.
- Are you surprised how bad
everything's gotten under Biden?
Obviously you didn't
vote for Biden,
but are you shocked
at only 11 months in,
just sort of across the
board, how bad it is?
- No, I'm not,
because this is what
progressive socialism
is all about.
And you know, when I was in
Congress back in 2011, 2012,
I just looked at what
they believed in.
I looked at their policies,
I looked at their
ideological agenda,
and I called them out
as socialist, Marxist,
some of 'em even communists.
And of course you remember,
I mean people went
sideways on me for that.
But guess what
happens now today?
They tell you, "We're
socialists, we're Marxists."
And so when you look at that
philosophy of governance,
I'm not surprised by
what they're doing.
They're doing exactly what
they believe in, what they say,
the fascism, the
suppression of free speech,
and freedom of expression,
calling parents,
who just want to
stand up and make sure
that their kids get a good
education, domestic terrorists?
And that's even
happening here in Texas,
where we have had two
parents in Round Rock,
just north of Austin, they
were arrested in their homes,
for just going and speaking
out at a school board meeting.
This is not the America,
this is not the Texas
that people want.
- You know, I gotta do
a mea culpa here, man,
because I remember when you
were talking about this stuff
way back when,
and I was a lefty,
and I was on "The Young
Turks" at the time.
And I'm sure I did
videos on their channel,
probably saying
that you were nuts,
because you saw it early,
and I wasn't there yet.
So times change, I suppose.
- Well, you know,
in Ecclesiastes,
King Solomon said, "There's
nothing new under the sun."
And George Santayana once said,
"Those who fail to
learn from history
are doomed to repeat it."
And I think that's the
important thing, again,
about leadership, and
being a statesman.
You have to say things
that people need to hear,
not what they want to hear.
And I was willing
to take the heat,
because look, in 1985, I went
through Checkpoint Charlie,
and I went over to East Berlin,
and I saw what it was like.
And my background is
in political science,
political theory.
And this is textbook stuff,
what we see
happening here, Dave,
and I think kudos to you
for having the courage
to stand up and say,
"Hey look, you know,
I can't believe in
this stuff anymore."
I mean, you live out
there in California,
you see what is going on.
This is not what
we're supposed to have
in a constitutional republic.
And it doesn't matter,
R and D after a name,
is starting to
mean less and less.
It's about how you
see the relationship
of the individual to the
institution of government.
It's very simple.
The Declaration of
Independence says
that the individual is supreme.
They are sovereign,
because their rights
come from a creator God.
If you're atheist or
whatever, that doesn't matter.
Your rights don't come from
an entity called government,
your life, your
liberty, your property,
as John Locke talk about
in the "Second Treatise
of Government,"
and your pursuit of happiness.
And we've got to get back
to those basic fundamentals.
- Are you worried that
just not enough people
care about what you
just said there?
You know, last time
I saw you actually
was at Glenn Beck's museum,
where he's put together
this extraordinary,
oh, sorry, what's the
name of the museum?
I don't know that.
- Oh, it's the American
Journey Experience.
- The American
Journey Experience,
it's absolutely incredible.
He has a trove of artifacts
that are unimaginable.
I mean, I literally
held the Olympic torch
that was held by Jesse
Owens, in front of Hitler.
I mean, I couldn't even believe
they would let me
touch that thing.
I mean, that's just amongst
the incredible stuff
that they have.
But when I was there
and I saw you there,
it sort of goes to what
you're saying right now,
there's a history that we have.
There are documents that
we have that freed us,
but not enough people
care about them,
or seem to be willing
to stand up for them.
Are you surprised by that?
What can we do to reverse that?
- I think it's
starting to happen.
And I will say one of the
positives that came out of COVID
was that parents are
actually starting to see
what their kids were
not being taught,
and they started
to pay attention.
And now for the first time,
you never heard about people
going to school board meetings
two years ago, but now they are.
And they're challenging
the status quo.
They're challenging the
institution of indoctrination,
and they don't like that.
And that's why they're fighting
back vehemently against it.
So I do think that there
is an awakening moment
here in the United
States of America.
But Alexander Fraser Tytler
talked about the
cycle of democracies.
And he said that, "A
democracy can't last
as a permanent
form of government.
It can normally last
until voters realize
they can vote their own largesse
from the public treasury."
And one of the pivot
points for that decline
is apathy and complacency.
And so I think that
we've seen that,
but it's not too late for
us to recover from it.
But this is an ideological
war that we're in.
There's no doubt about it,
between constitutional
conservatism
and progressive
socialism and Marxism.
- Where do you think
some of the, say,
disaffected liberals,
maybe libertarians,
like the wider group
right now that I think,
I've been saying for a while,
it's sort of woke
verse everybody.
And it's our job as
everybody, to kinda figure out
how we can work together,
how we can disagree,
and agree to
disagree, et cetera.
How do you think
that thing can work?
Or do you think
- I do think it can work,
and it has to be based
upon individual rights,
freedoms, and liberties.
And you know, I'll give
you case and point,
just recently, I was
up in New York City,
and went out to get
something to eat
after a Fox interview
and everything.
And I walked into this diner,
and guy asked me, "Where's
your COVID shot card?"
And I said, "I don't
have a COVID shot card,
I'm visiting here from Texas."
He said, "Well, you
can't eat here."
I think that's going to be
the thing that unites people,
because I remember
my mother and father,
once upon a time, they were told
that they couldn't
eat in certain places,
because of their skin color.
But now we're being told that
we can't eat in certain places
because someone has decided
that we have to get this thing
injected into our bodies.
And I really believe that
when people start to hear
that they no longer have
control over their own bodies,
that's going to
be a rallying cry.
Just the same as you've
seen when Terry McAuliffe
stands up in a debate and says,
"Parents don't have
a right to decide
what their children
are being taught."
Oh man, you brought
out people in Virginia
that would have never cared
about a Virginia
gubernatorial race.
And so a year ago, Joe
Biden wins Virginia
by 11 or 12 points.
A year later, they lose
Virginia by two or three points.
So I think that that's the
shift that we see happening,
when you start to touch
people's individual rights,
freedom, and liberty,
when you start to reach
inside their homes,
or affect their bodies,
then people are gonna
wake up to this.
- Yeah, it used to be
my body, my choice.
Not so much for them anymore.
But you mentioned
two to three points.
Speaking of two to three points,
the last senatorial
campaign in Texas,
Ted Cruz only beat Beto
by about three points.
I think it was 2 1/2,
if I'm not mistaken.
It was a lot closer.
- Yeah, 2 1/2.
- Yeah, it was a lot
closer than people thought.
What does that tell you about
what's happening in Texas?
Is Austin getting weird
filtering throughout the state?
Is that what's happening?
- Well, I think
that the Beto effect
that happened in 2018 was
that he was a new person,
and the media built
this aura around him.
And there was a lot
of angst and anxiety
against Senator Cruz.
But now the cat's out the bag,
and we know who this Mr O'Rourke
is, and what he stands for.
And he's completely antithetical
to Texas principles and values.
But when you look at what
has happened in Texas,
when you look at what has
happened in many red states,
California used
to be a red state.
I mean, this was the state
that gave us Richard Nixon,
and Ronald Reagan.
What has happening in Texas
is that we have had governors
going to blue states,
and saying, "Why don't you
pick up and move your business,
or your corporation here,
because we have better policies,
and you can
economically thrive."
But the thing that is happening
is that as they bring
this workforce with them,
no one is talking to them
saying, "Don't screw it up
when you move to this
new place, okay?"
I can leave California
Silicon Valley,
because this place sucks.
And so they ended
up coming here,
and they wanna
vote the same way.
Now there are individuals
that are leaving California,
Illinois, New York,
and New Jersey,
for all the right reasons.
But when you have
this mass transplant,
and I call it the locust effect.
I mean, people go to
the very good, thriving,
fertile grounds like
California used to be,
and they chew it
up and destroy it.
And then they look and see
where else they can go.
But I will tell you,
hats off to Elon Musk,
because earlier in November,
Elon Musk put out a tweet to
the people there in Austin,
saying, admonishing them,
saying, "Don't let Austin
become the new San Francisco,"
because the people in Austin,
since they defunded the police,
got all woke and
everything like that,
they've seen a 66%
increase in violent crime,
71% increase in homicide.
The homeless situation there
is absolutely disgusting
and appalling, people don't go
downtown in Austin at night.
But yet they still
voted down a proposition
to re-fund the police.
And so I think
that's, at the core,
something that's
going to change,
because all of a sudden,
when people realize that
their personal safety
and security is at risk,
they'll back away from this.
- Can you get those
people though, to change?
I get that you might be
able to get the true Texan,
that's been there
for a lifetime,
to go, "Okay, we really
gotta vote the right way."
But the ones that come
from Silicon Valley,
it takes sort of a
little smacking around
for them to realize
that they're leaving
the thing that they voted for.
- It does, and I think
it's another thing
that we have to do
is teach them about
the history of Texas, or
the history of Georgia,
or Tennessee, and why
they're successful.
And understand that Texas is
the only state in the union
that fought for and won
its independence by itself.
But I think the other
thing that we have to do,
without a doubt, is
understand that, you know,
find out where those
strong crossing points,
like you and I just discussed,
where you get the 60 to 65%.
Because I think
it's that 35 to 40%,
you're probably just not
gonna get through to them.
But let's go after the
people that understand,
and that's why we
had such success
when I was the
chairman of the party,
going down into the
Rio Grande Valley.
And we told the people in
the Hispanic community,
who had never seen a
Republican Party chairman
in the Rio Grande
Valley previous to that,
"Your principles and values
are our principles of values."
You know, it wasn't
about the outreach.
It was about the engagement.
Outreach means you show up
at a Black History Month,
Hispanic American
Heritage Month,
and then people
never see you again,
until a couple of months
before an election.
But when you're there all
the time, 24 seven, 365,
talking about those common
points that you can expand upon,
then people will
rally to your cause.
And then again,
I think that this
is more of a
philosophical, ideological,
cultural basis that we
have to approach things,
and not just about
political parties anymore.
- So I hate to do the identity
politics thing, obviously,
and I know you don't
want to do it either,
but it exists, whether
we talk about it or not.
- Yeah, that's
their battleground.
- That's what they've got.
As you know, I campaigned
with Larry Elder,
who's a good friend of mine.
I saw what the
machine did to him,
for Joe Biden to show up here
the day before the election,
refused to say Larry's name,
call him, "A Trump clone,"
a guy who grew up in South
Central LA, son of a janitor.
I mean, it's so
extraordinarily evil,
the stuff that Gavin Newsom did,
the evil ads that Reed
Hastings from Netflix
put out about Larry,
"Black face of white supremacy,"
according to "LA Times,"
you know all this stuff,
there's obviously gonna
be a version of that
that's going to come after you.
You've been through
the game before,
but are you ready for it,
in a gubernatorial thing,
which is different than
congressional race,
and being a talking
head on Fox, et cetera?
- Well, absolutely,
and one of the things
about being here in
the state of Texas,
the Republican Party
of Texas was founded
on Independence Day of 1867,
by 150 black men
in Houston, Texas.
One of the early chairman
was Norris Wright Cuney.
You think about Juneteenth,
and you think about how recently
they just dedicated a statue
to a man who was a former slave,
State Senator Matthew Gaines,
who was instrumental
in establishing
Texas A&M University,
and Prairie View A&M University.
And he's buried there
at Texas A&M University.
Guess who's also buried there,
on the campus of Texas A&M?
You know, President George
H. W. Bush and his wife.
And so when you talk
about these things,
and you use history
to illuminate people,
and you just talk
about the real party
of systemic racism, has
been the Democrat Party.
I often tell folks,
"There are two ways
that you can enslave people.
One is that you work
them for no pay.
And the other is that you
pay them for no work."
And tell me what this
party has done that
in the history of the
United States of America?
So I think that as long
as you stand strong,
and you always go on the
offense, not on the defense,
you put them back
on their heels,
you know, all this talk about
white supremacy and racism.,
I have yet to see
anyone on the left
speak out against
Margaret Sanger.
Margaret Sanger create Planned
Parenthood for one reason,
because she believed that blacks
were undesirables
and human weeds.
And yet we see 71 to 73% of
Planned Parenthood clinics
in minority communities.
So as long as we
are the aggressor,
as long as we are pitting
them on their heels,
we don't let them
define the narrative.
And I think that's the thing
that the military taught me,
and that's how we're
going to make sure
that we don't allow them to
dictate and define who I am.
- Are there other
things going on in Texas
that maybe we're
not hearing about,
from a national perspective,
that you guys are aware of,
or that you think are
the keys to winning,
and creating a
flourishing state?
- Oh, sure, without a doubt,
the property tax system
that we have here, sixth
highest in the country.
And it's really Marxist,
because here in Texas,
who would have ever thought
you can pay off your land,
you can pay off your mortgage,
you can never own your home.
So we've got to
transition away from that.
A lot of people maybe
remember this past February,
where Texas looked like
North Korea at night,
on a satellite image map.
We have such oil and
gas resources here,
we should never
go into the dark,
but it was an over-reliance
on wind and solar.
So that's another big
issue for people here,
without a doubt-
- Wait, wait, Colonel West,
didn't AOC tell me
that was because
they're not green enough?
I thought it was 'cause
- Yeah, well, I would like
for her to come down here
and spend that time with us.
You know, green
energy may be nice,
but it can only give
you about three to 6%.
We had wind and solar,
we gave them 23 to 26% of
our energy distribution plan,
and they just weren't
able to own up to that.
And so on that Valentine's
Day in February,
we went from 23% down to 3%,
and we did not do
the winterization
for our natural gas.
And so those plants weren't
ready to fire up as well.
So that's a big issue also.
But without a doubt, the
border security issue,
and then also the
election integrity issue,
because there are some
people here in Texas,
Democrats that
should be in jail.
They should not be walking free,
based upon some of the
things that they did,
especially down
in Harris County,
which is the largest
county here in Texas,
third largest, third or
fourth largest in the county.
- So how do you address
election integrity
without everyone saying
you're a conspiracy theorist,
or a whack job?
Because again, when I
was out there with Larry,
every single person,
I'm not kidding you,
I think every single
person who came up to me
to say something, would
say the same two things.
They'd say, "Does
Larry have a chance?
And will it be legit?"
And I would always say,
"Yes," to number one,
and, "I have no
idea," to number two.
But once you go down that path,
they call you a
conspiracy theorist,
all the stuff, all the stuff.
So how do you tackle
election integrity,
in a way that's gonna
actually fix something?
- Well, I think the
most important thing
you gotta realize
is that there are
unconstitutional actions
that happened in November, 2020.
No one can debate about that.
In five battleground states,
Georgia, Pennsylvania, Michigan,
Wisconsin, and Arizona,
you had governors,
secretary of states,
and judges changing
election law.
And sadly, we even
had that happen here
in the state of Texas,
where our governor
changed early voting
from two weeks to three weeks.
You can't do that, and so
that's unconstitutional.
So that's one thing
we have to tackle.
Then we need to make sure we
have secretary of state offices
that are vetting
these voting machines,
and saying, "These
are the approved list
of voting machines that
we'll have in this state.
And if you violate that, then
there has to be consequences."
The problem is, you can
put all the laws you want
on the books, Dave, but
if you don't enforce them,
and there are no consequences,
then the left is gonna
continue to do exactly that.
It goes right back to
what Joseph Stalin said,
"It is not the person that
casts the ballot that matters,
it's the person that counts
the ballot that matters."
And so we've gotta make
sure these machines
are not tied up to the internet.
We've gotta make sure
we have paper trail,
audible background to it.
And we also need to make sure
that the people that
are supposed to be there
as poll workers and whatever,
they're able to do their duties.
But when we look at the Harris
County Clerk Chris Hollins,
who opened up curbside
voting locations,
in nine different Democrat
precincts in Harris County,
he's still walking around free.
He was gonna mail out 2.7
million unsolicited ballots.
He's still walking around free.
So there has to be consequences.
- I literally tried to show
the poll worker my ID to vote,
and he would not look at it.
That tells you all
you need to know.
I could be literally,
literally anyone.
Speaking of the election stuff,
so, you know, Texas obviously
had some election laws
that were passed,
Georgia's had some,
we're sorta seeing them pop
up throughout the country.
And of course the way
the media treats it,
this is to stop black
people somehow from voting,
because apparently black
people don't have ID.
Do you have an ID?
Were you able to figure
out how to get an ID?
- Yeah, let me-
(Dave laughing)
- Let's not get your docs,
let's not get your docs,
I'll take your word for it.
- Trust with Verify, folks.
- We're gonna blur
that, that could,
what are you doing,
what are you doing?
- That's my license
to carry card.
I mean, the left,
they don't wanna see
my license to carry card.
- They definitely
don't wanna see that.
We're gonna blur it anyway.
Connor, we're
blurring that thing.
Save this guy's
career right now.
- Hey, show up at my house,
and you're going
to meet somebody.
- Ah, fair enough,
that was a challenge
more than a cell
phone right there.
But when you see that, you know,
I went through all
of the bullet points
about showing ID,
about making sure
that we're gonna
count things properly,
and cameras, and you can't
canvas right then and there.
But they turned the entire thing
into this as a bunch of racists,
trying to stop
minorities from voting.
Just not the case,
just not the case.
- Then Southwest
Airlines is racist,
American Airlines, Delta,
all these places
are racist because-
- Mini golf, mini
golf, you need an ID.
- Absolutely, and every
place that you have to go
to show an ID
therefore is racist.
And again, that comes
back to what I said, Dave,
we've got to go on offense,
and we've got to just
show the hypocrisy,
and the real idiocy of what
these guys are talking about,
because all they have to
fall back on is this racist.
You know, when Joe Biden
gave his inaugural address,
talking about unity, he was
not talking about unity.
He was talking about conformity.
And if you don't
conform, he said,
"We're gonna call you a
racist, a white supremacist."
And what has happened
this entire year?
If you don't agree with
their ideological agenda,
black, white, Hispanic,
Asian, whatever,
you're a racist, and
you're a white supremacist.
- What about on the
mandate side of this?
The vaccine mandate
side of this?
Texas has largely remained open,
the couple of times
that I've been to Texas
in the last two years,
have been the rare
moments of freedom,
that plus Florida and
Tennessee, for me at least.
Do you think Abbott did
basically the right thing?
Could he have done more?
Should we all have
just ignored everything
right from the beginning?
I mean, I think
in retrospect now,
it's like, man, we just
shoulda told people,
"If you wanna wear
a mask, wear a mask,
and just get out of our
way, and that's it."
- We were dealing with the
least most dangerous pandemic
the world has ever seen.
A 99.9% recovery rate,
but what did we do?
We destroyed people's individual
liberties and freedoms,
and we can't allow
that to happen.
And yes, we did have a
shutdown here in Texas
that almost lasted
about 11 months,
about 2.5, 2.7 million
Texans lost jobs,
about 10,000 small
businesses closed.
And right now, we
still have Texans
that are losing their jobs,
because of some
private businesses
are forcing them to
get a jab in their arm.
And so we have been, a lot of,
I think about 30 legislators
in the Texas State
House and Senate
have asked them to have
a fourth special session
to make sure that they pass a
law, not an executive order,
but pass a law against
these mandates.
They've done that in Georgia.
They did that in Florida,
and the legislature came
back in executive session.
So I think the
Texas will wanna see
a little bit more action,
and to make sure that we stay
one of the most free
and independent states
that you have here in the
United States of America.
- So what this always
comes down to for me,
I bring it up on my
show all the time,
is that the states, it's sort
of where we started here,
that the states are
gonna kind of go
in their separate directions.
And in some ways, that's okay,
because of the
federalist system.
And it gives you more
power over your state.
But what do you
think, ideologically,
those that sort of believe in
what we're talking about here,
what do you think we do
when they just will
not leave us alone?
Like to me, the more that
Texas, Florida, Tennessee,
some of those other
states, flourish,
and it's very obvious that
they're gonna flourish,
'cause they'll bring
in the right people,
they'll believe in
the right things.
The other guys are never
gonna let them alone.
They're gonna always use
them as the scapegoat
and everything else.
And I could see the
average person in Texas
going, "You know, I'm sick
of my freaking tax money
paid to the federal government,
being sent to some idiot,
who is voting for Gavin
Newsom in California."
I mean, that doesn't
seem tenable to me
for a very long time.
- No, you're absolutely right.
And that's one of the
leverages that we do have
here in Texas and other states,
are the remittances
that we send back
to the federal government,
because if the federal
government is not owning up
to its constitutional
duties and responsibilities,
like we see with
the border here,
then Texas look and say,
"Okay, it's gonna cost us
X amount of billions of dollars
to get this thing rectified."
And that's what we're not
gonna be sending back to you,
as far as emphasis to
the federal government.
So everything has to come
back to the rule of law.
Everything has to come back
to that republican
form of government,
which the federal government
is supposed to provide
to every state in the union.
And we have to stand on that.
And I think it's so important
that just the same as the
blue states came together
with the national popular
vote interstate compact,
to try to undermine
electoral college,
red states need to form a wall.
They need to lock shields,
and make sure that they
are doing what is right
abiding by the rule of law,
and saying that we're gonna
put up an impenetrable front,
if you continue to
try to undermine
our freedoms and
liberties in our states.
Remember, in the
Declaration of Independence
it says, "Free and
independent states
created these United
States of America,"
and I think we need to go
back and reassert that.
- Have states
actually done that?
I actually don't know.
They've basically, if
the federal government
is in dereliction of duty,
they can basically say,
"Hey, we're just not
gonna pay you that money
that you've been
collecting from us,"
or a portion of it or something?
- I think you're starting
to see some challenges.
You look at Oklahoma right now,
they're saying that
they're not gonna allow
the federal government
to come down,
and just use their
National Guard.
And of course there's a
fight going back there.
And so, but I think that
that's something that we,
it's about the
power of the purse.
I think states
need to understand
that power that they have,
and start strangling
the resources
going back to the
federal government.
Because right now, when you look
at what the federal government
is doing with our tax dollars,
you just brought it out,
it's going to bail out
blue states when they fail.
And so I don't think that
we want to see that happen.
- Yeah, what do you do
when you have a state
that basically is
doing the right stuff?
And then, you know, we
talked about Austin before,
there's some backwards
stuff going on there.
What would you, as governor, do,
if you sat down with
the mayor of Austin,
and you felt the policies were
going in the wrong direction?
When I was there last time,
it wasn't quite San Francisco,
but there's a lot of homeless,
et cetera, et cetera.
What do you do as the governor?
What kind of leverage
do you actually have?
- Well, I think it's
first and foremost,
you've gotta educate
the electorate
that lives within
that municipality,
and get them to understand
that this is something
that you can do by petition,
by referendum and what have you.
But without a doubt,
my responsibility
is for all Texans.
And when I see that you have
these district attorneys
that are saying, "We're
not gonna prosecute people
for anything at $750 or less,"
when you have these
judges here in Texas
that are releasing criminals
out into the streets,
you know, when you dig into
the Texas State Constitution,
you find that the governor
is able to impeach,
or start impeachment proceedings
against these judges.
You have to work with
the Texas State House,
but you have to stay
within the rule of law.
You don't wanna be seen
as some type of dictator,
or anything like that.
But you've gotta get
people to understand
that I will stand up
for the rule of law.
We'll make sure that
I protect the safety
and security of individuals,
but you gotta empower the people
to be able to do these things.
And again, I think that you
see an awakening toward that.
- Do you think conservatives
have to use a little more power
than they would want to perhaps?
- Yeah, you know, one of
the things I always say
is that Republicans
have to stop bringing
a plastic spoon to a gunfight,
because they always just think,
"Nah, they're not going
to do anything about it."
So we cannot continue
to allow them
to kick sand in our face.
We gotta stand up,
and I think that's what
people are looking for.
And so when we make the
case, I mean, we win.
You look at what
happened in Virginia,
look what almost
happened in New Jersey.
The left knows that they're
gonna have an Armageddon,
a political Armageddon
in the midterm elections,
that's going to make Barack
Obama look pretty bad.
I mean, he lost
63 seats in 2010.
Joe Biden's gonna
lose even more.
But we have to understand
that we can't have
the peaks and valleys.
We have to have a steady state.
And I tell people that the
most important elections
are those elections that are
local, the city councils,
the school boards, the county
commissions, the DA races,
all of those things
are the closest
to the individual
citizens down there,
we gotta start
focusing on those.
- In our last
couple minutes here,
what else is on your mind?
Maybe not purely
political these days,
I know you're also
a man of faith,
that frames a lot of
your beliefs, of course.
What else is on your mind
in this holiday season?
- Well, college
football, I love that,
being brought up down South.
And so I always get honed
up for college football.
But without a doubt, I
mean the blessing of life
that came into our family,
with our new grandson,
and this'll be his
first Christmas.
And on December the 1st, we
turned on the house lights,
and just seeing
his face light up.
You know, we have many
challenges that we have here,
but we're still
the greatest nation
that the world has ever known.
But I think that now's the time,
when you look at a grandson,
you look at our children
or grandchildren,
everyone, just stand up and
fight for what is right,
and make sure that we are
not the first generation
that does not pass
on something better
to subsequent
generations, 'cause again,
my dad was born in 1920,
and my mom was born
in 1931 down South.
And here I am, on a
national televised program,
talking to you, Dave, that's
what America is all about.
The equality of opportunity,
and not the equality
of outcomes.
- Colonel West, we live in
a time with very few people
who speak as cleanly and
clearly, and honestly as you do,
so I'm proud to
call you a friend.
And would you be willing,
would you be willing
to have a crazy
right-winger like me,
maybe open for you
on a campaign stop?
- Absolutely.
- Larry'll show you my resume,
it's pretty decent.
- I think your resume
is real decent.
And I'd love to see
you here in Texas,
because so goes Texas,
so goes America.
And so goes America,
so goes the free world.
So Texas is important
for the free world.
- Colonel Allen West, I
wish you luck, my friend.
Merry Christmas to you.
- Christmas, take care, Dave.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews,
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe, and
click the notification bell.